[Applaudissements]
pas de surprise pour ce second tour
alain suguenot remporte pour la
cinquième fois à l'élection municipale à
beaune 56 5% des suffrages pour le maire
sortant
il met à peine plus d'un électeur sur
trois s'est déplacé pour aller aux urnes
ce dimanche
mon avis avec l'électorat des personnes
qui ne se sont pas déplacés je pense
qu'on pouvait accrocher 60 % ce qui
aurait été miraculé on part de cinq
listes on n'est pas du tout dans le
périmètre de 2014 un début d'accord je
crois qu'à bonne certains disaient que
c'était le visage de ces rixes
alors je vais pas sur dame est prêt à
l'ac texte mais en tous les cas je suis
très heureux d'être un irréductible
gaulois et que les les beaunoises et les
vaudois est en vie tout simplement
continuer ensemble une élection un
confortable qu'à l'accoutumée mais un
socle d'électeurs suffisant pour
devancer eric mono qui dépasse de peu
les 30%
il a une implantation quelconque très
très forte et les gens n'ont pas tenu
compte de des affaires d'un
environnement d'un manque de structures
à beaune
ils ont continué à gothenburg je suis je
suis même surpris également déçu la
candidate écologie sans accord avec eric
mono elle doit se contenter de 12 9%
un petit peu le principe dans marche de
prendre à droite de prendre à gauche
voilà donc effectivement je pense qu'il
a réussi à capter une partie des voix de
la gauche
avec cette élection la ville de beaune
et fidèle à sa réputation conservatrice